but for the women after we had our
wonderful presentation from Alex do you
think women have a sort of lineup like
that to get what they essentially want
from men and that's either money time or
whatever they value in a man
women will always know what they're
doing like I said earlier people might
bats like they're vulnerable but people
are not dumb and if you're a woman who's
realistic with yourself and you're
playing a game you want to talk about
hoes and strippers and girls in the
streets there's girls out there that
know how to play men but also the men
know what they're doing they they
actually enjoy it so it's a mutual risk
like
like everyone's get what they want in
the day but I think women do know
how to play the game but I think there's
women personally in my circle that don't
play the game but there's women that can
play the same as that game
simple as obviously it's a bit different
from a man woman will use sex to get
what they want from a man
I think women develop much more
sophisticated games very early on quite
naturally so I was a massive physics
teacher for a while and I noticed that
pretty much 15 14 starts as long as even
12 like you know year seven these girls
are already lying they're already
practicing like triangular relationships
like love triangles because all girls
watch is romance right the the the
eternals you know
they idolize that stuff they practice
for these complex situations and in fact
some and often times they actually want
these situations to happen because they
enjoy these scenarios kind of like every
man wants to be the man every girl wants
to be the guy that you know the girl
that guy is fight over inherently and so
women naturally develop much more
sophisticated ways of playing the game
also they have something you want right
sex so naturally they start learning how
to filter and how to tend to play the
game but because of social media it
changed the game too much in favor of
attention
before I think I think there was other
things in the courting process right she
would she would kind of think more about
like his ability to take care of her XYZ
but now because of social media isn't
under the dopamine you get from like
having people look at you and like your
stuff and people think you're great and
having that clout young girls are got
kind of seduced into this like I want to
play this game but women are constantly
getting my attention and validation that
they want look at it there's no need
there's no need past that point to give
anything up they're getting the
intention and validation of men usually
don't just give out for free I want to
hear your tears uh answers to my
question
I'm just interested yeah I feel like
I've been talking a lot so I'm just you
know I'm just taking everything in but I
I I agree I think I think women know how
to play the game I think we know what we
want to do but I think that's a general
thing not every woman knows exactly what
a game is or what they maybe even want I
was gonna say I just no don't worry I
just feel like
I know we're not talking completely
generally but I feel like
opinions here are very much like black
and white I think that's why I've kind
of just been very in the you know fly on
the wall type thing
um and I also don't like to interrupt
that's kind of why I've just been
sitting here but I think at the end of
the day we all men and women we all know
what we want at the end of the day so
I think modern women don't know what
they want I was gonna say in regards in
regards to like women naturally learning
that it actually a lot of it starts at
home and it's very very common you see
this in studies where the daughters will
and the daughter and the Mother start
competing for the father's attention and
it's very common because it's this
little girl that she almost takes
priority because how many times do we
see like a daughter who has that her
father wrapped around her finger right
especially if he's like very wealthy or
whatever and all this so it actually
starts a lot of it can start very very
young and it's really common that it
starts young especially when you've got
the father in the home and that's almost
how she learns how to get the male
attention she doesn't you don't even
realize that it's from the parents but
it is
so just to play what about the other
ones that didn't have a dad or vice
versa because sometimes it doesn't
always just play on social media yeah of
course I've been but I mean it starts it
can happen at school as well like to
start at school
social media
the girls go on their Instagram and they
see that the girls the women who have
the attention who are being shared
modern day yeah yeah that's that's
modern day in terms of online but I'm
talking like let's say just classic in
the playground or something like or
you're just like at school I I agree
with you because like I would say um my
family has a lot of like high Achievers
and because that's kind of how we would
compete for our parents attention it was
like doing good at sports or doing good
at like whatever yeah so you get
validation yeah yeah yeah I agree it's
true so is this
um yeah so yeah it should be on
that was on yeah yeah so young boys
typically they try to gain their parents
approval through achievements and
accolades yes whereas girls typically
use the
the manipulation tactic of I'm I'm
basically upset or I'm hurt which which
makes it brings out the nurturing so it
bring it brings out that side of men
that's protective and makes men want to
protect the daughters which gives them
the attention it was a manipulation
tactic but then with nowadays if we look
at Society how many men are in their
children life and their daughter's like
how many women are in their son's life
like if we look at both there's a lot of
men that are not there women that are
not there for their kids vice versa
they're growing up without a full family
loving them and understanding what to
look for in a manner in a woman which I
agree is wrong however so how do we look
for it now that's what I'm saying like
romance movies Instagram social media
which I believe an episode needs to be
done on by the way yeah I truly believe
social media Instagram uh erotic novels
everything else oh on that point as well
for anyone who's not seen it
sex life a documentary on Netflix if you
haven't watched it you [__] need to
it's only 10 episodes but that series
projects everything we've gone through
today it's an I think a good an episode
and that will be [__] amazing give
that give that series a go because yeah
men you're going to be pissed so I have
I have a question for the man
what can a modern woman do for a man to
outperform what traditional women have
offered in the past
[Music]
what can a modern woman so what can a
modern woman do for a man to outperform
the traditional women
that what traditional women have offered
in the past I would say I would say help
with his career because back back in the
day tradition like the women didn't have
the opportunities in the career space to
open doors or to provide like even even
simple things is just like I remember I
was dating a girl once we went and
trained to the gym together and a guy
she was like attractive a guy gave her
like like a free foam thing for training
and she just gave it to me and I was
just like she used her perks to serve my
life in some way so I'll probably say
the difference is I forgot if a woman
can help a man in his career in some way
that's something that traditional women
traditionally couldn't have done because
they didn't have access to that well I
would also I would also say instead of
instead of trying to outdo the
traditional women I would say bring back
what traditional women have their values
right so be beautiful be youthful be
pure don't just be sleeping around with
everybody be feminine be submissive and
support your mind but I think the
question is as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible